tristan cabello bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous bonjour en tout cas pour vous
merci d'être avec nous en direct pour
cette édition spéciale sur rt france
sont là vous avez sans doute entendu nos
invités c'est une journée complexe on ne
sait pas bien à quoi s'attendre
quel est votre état d'esprit aujourd'hui
pour vous est-ce qu'on connaîtra dans
quelques heures le nouveau nom du
président les états unis oui écoutez moi
j'ai vraiment l'impression d'une d'une
amérique qui est très fatigué c'est à
dire qu'on peut faire beaucoup de
reproches à donald trump on peut pas de
faire le reproche d'avoir menti sur son
programme il a vraiment tenu ses mots il
avait monté lui ces mots sur son
programme et donc il voulait vraiment
que l'amérique as l'amérique soit great
guen et moi j'ai envie de dire
l'amérique c'était bien pour qui avant
pas pour les noirs pas retour des
immigrés pas pour les gays pas pour les
femmes pas pour les pauvres et donc il a
mis son programme en oeuvre
c'est à dire que tous les jours il y
avait des tweets racistes xénophobes
sexistes et quand on vivait ici au plus
proche de la démocratie américaine
on avait peur on avait peur tous les
jours pour nos amis pour nous mêmes pour
nos droits mais j'ai envie de dire qu'on
aurait pu vraiment survivre à ce
folklore
s'il n'y avait pas eu le coc vide c'est
à dire que canto coville est arrivé on
sait tous vraiment rendu compte que ça
n'était pas une blague que tous ces gens
qui le critiquent qui avec les détestait
durant tout son terme
là il n'a rien fait pour les sauver en
effet les gens qui sont morts dus qu'au
guide dans les tous premiers deux
premiers mois de l'épidémie c'était en
priorité des pauvres c'était en priorité
des noirs des latinos des sans papiers
donc je crois qu'on a vraiment affaire à
une amérique qui est très fatigué qui
est à bout de souffle
et voilà donc une amérique vraiment très
fatigué et un tiers vous parliez de
l'économie qui était finalement assez
florissante
voilà en tout cas les signaux étaient au
vert avant cette épidémie de coronavirus
selon vous est-ce que donald trump
pourrait se fracasser justement sur ces
chiffres de l'économie qui sont devenus
très mauvais la suite de cette pandémie
est-ce qu'on peut exprimer les choses
comme ça oui tout à fait oui tout à fait
alors je crois qu'il faut quand même
revenir sur le bilan économique de
donald trump
c'est à dire qu'il disait lui même qu'il
y avait en effet un chômage qui était
très très bas aux états unis un peu
moins de 3% mais se doteront s'est rendu
compte c'est que ce chômage
cette économie c'était en fait un
château de cartes et que le coville a
détruit sa en moins d'un mois
pourquoi c'était un château de cartes
parce que la plupart des américains dans
même s'il était employé en fait
combinait plusieurs jobs pour subvenir à
leurs besoins quelquefois 2-3-4 job
c'est vraiment pour payer les factures
il fallait rappeler quand même que sous
la présidence trump 60% des américains
n'avaient pas 600 $ d'héparine ça veut
dire que le moindre problème quotidien
c'est-à-dire un frigo qui ne marchent
plus une voiture qui ne marchent plus un
ordinateur qu'il faut racheter pouvait
les faire basculer dans la dans la dans
la dans la pauvreté
il faut aussi rappeler aux uns qu'aux
états unis un test pour le coc vite
quand on a pas d'assurances ses 180
dollars donc quand on a pas d'assurance
et qu'on a seulement 600 dollars d'
épargne à la banque etc on est une
famille avec deux personnes et un enfant
ben c'est 600 $ là ils partent donc il
faut vraiment rappeler ici que
l'économie de donald trump c'était des
chiffres qui étaient très très bon
c'était une réalité qui était quand même
très terne aussi vous parliez tristan
cabello de cette division c'est quelque
chose qui frappe quand on est ici aux
etats unis quand on parle voilà aux
citoyens dans la rue dans les taxis
n'importe où on nous parle de cette
fracture de cette division voire de
cette haine entre les populations vous
le constatez également
oui alors c'est une division qu'on
constate j'ai envie de dire tous les
jours avec d'un côté l'amérique j'allais
dire des colons celle du centre blanche
du midwest du sud
et puis de l'autre côté cette amérique
qui serait plutôt en amérique style
ellis island beaucoup plus multiculturel
beaucoup plus globalisé qui ne peut plus
se parler et là on voit fleurir par
exemple dans les blocs et dans les
revues populaire des articles sur
comment supporter l'oncle trump heist ou
au dîner de thanksgiving et vice versa
et parce que les gens ne se parlent plus
mais ce que j'ai envie de dire c'est que
la deuxième amérique c'est elle cette
amérique beaucoup plus multiculturel
donc plus globalisé c'est la nouvelle
amérique et l amérique du futur c'est à
dire que scientifiquement
démographiquement
c'est cette amérique qui va être
majoritaire dans les 15 20 prochaines
années
traitant ou cabello pour autant cette
fracture cette division est ce qu'on
peut l'imputer à la politique de donald
trump ou c'est un raccourci
il est tout à fait évident que donald
trump est mis de l'huile sur le feu il
serait tout à fait injuste de lui
imputer la situation actuelle c'est une
situation qui peut être imputée aux
républicains et aux démocrates et
démocrates ne sont pas du tout innocent
dans la situation qui qui est arrivé
dans les trois derniers mois aux etats
unis
il faut quand même refaire le bilan 1
de barack obama il faut quand même
rappeler que sous barack obama et ben
c'est là qu'a vu le mouvement qui a vu
naître le mouvement backlight mat heures
c'est à dire des choses ne sont ne se
sont pas forcément améliorée sous barack
obama obamacare a été pour beaucoup
d'américains quand même à un énorme
problème c'est une avancée mais ça a été
aussi un énorme problème
et puis il faut quand même rappeler que
hillary clinton a fait une très mauvaise
campagne en 2016 que les mandat de bill
clinton ne sont pas tout à fait innocent
non plus donc non percutée même la
situation de la crise à donald trump est
tout à fait injuste ce n'est pas le seul
responsable c'est trente ans de
politiques qui ont mené à cette
situation tout à fait délétère
spécifiquement pour des minorités aux
états unis merci tristan cabello d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
depuis washington